hey everyone how's it going hope you are
well so today we're going to talk about
how I make my career decisions in tech
speaking of making decisions in a tech
career I have a brand new podcast in
case L haven't heard it's called if-else
and I am so so so excited to share with
you all in each episode we meet a
software developer who's at a crossroads
either they need to make a technical
decision or a career when they're at an
if-else choice if you will and we call
in experts and people from the industry
to help them make that decision I am the
host of this podcast and I am so excited
to share with you all about it because
it's genuinely something I am so
interested in and really want to do more
of in helping people to make these tough
career decisions in tech the podcast is
brought to you by CTO AI they are the
makers of the ops platform and I've been
partnering with them on season 1 of this
podcast and it's been so fun working
with them on this we have three episodes
out right now so you can listen to them
wherever you listen to your podcast
there is a link in the description box
down below so please check it out and I
really hope you enjoy so on this topic
of decision-making I wanted to create a
video about making career decisions
there is going to be a video in the
future about making technical decisions
which i think is a bit of a different
topic than this one so today we're going
to talk about career stuff and what I
mean career decision things like what
company are you going to work for what
job were you going to do what area of
tech are you going to be in sometimes
what city are you going to live in as
well the advice that I'm going to give
is all based on my own personal
experiences they're not prescriptive
there's a lot of other ways to make
these decisions and if there's anything
that I don't mention I would love for
you all to leave comments down below to
let me know how you all make career
decisions I do know for a fact that
there are lots of software engineers who
watch my videos who can give a lot of
their own insight and have gone through
lots of different paths and journeys
than I have and I would love to hear
from y'all so make sure to let me know
what you think about this topic too so
before we dive into the how I kind of
wanted to dive into the why of career
decisions and I think one of the
foundational things that I learned on
early in my career around career ladders
and journeys and stuff is that it's not
actually a ladder I read somewhere once
in my first year of working that instead
of thinking about a ladder where there's
only one way up and one way down think
about it in terms of like a jungle gym
where there's lots of ways up and
there's lots of ways down and at the end
of the day you might reach a different
destination than someone who started off
at the same place that you're at which I
think conceptually makes a lot of sense
because life is so different from person
to person and the opportunities and
experiences that you're offered are
always going to differ and everything is
serendipitous there's no way of knowing
everything is just ambiguous and who
knows what's gonna happen in the future
and what has happened in the past so if
we're going on this career jungle-gym
sort of analogy then you can imagine
that the next step that you take from
your first one is going to affect what
opportunities you have after that as
well I've also heard this whole jungle
gym analogy talked about in terms of
doors where you maybe have a set of
doors in front of you and then you
choose one and then when you go through
that door there's another set of doors
that are presented to you because you
chose that one door and that is just
kind of all to talk about how whatever
decision that you make is going to open
new doors and it's going to really set
you off on a journey toward some
direction in life and your career
basically this is a really complicated
way of saying that there is no one path
or one journey or right or wrong way to
have a career in tech it's just based on
how you make decisions and how you want
to lead your career but I do want to
really hone in on the fact that whatever
decisions you make today will affect
what decisions you make tomorrow five
years from now and ten years from now no
pressure but I mean like you said
there's no right or wrong
so there's no incorrect answer there's
no correct answer it's really just based
on how life reveals itself to you and I
mean I think it's also safe to say that
a career is a really big important part
of your life especially if you're going
to work full-time you're just gonna
spend a lot of time working in your life
and a lot of people derive their sense
of fulfillment and their sense of like
self in their work and that's totally
fine and also if you don't that's also
totally fine but I think it's something
you know career along with so many other
things that are worth giving this level
of thought to for how you want to
navigate it the other important factor
in all this which makes it kind of even
more important to think about and be
really intentional about is the fact
that the tech industry moves super super
quickly especially if you work in parts
of the tech industry that are like
product oriented I feel like the
industry reinvents itself every two to
five years in terms of what technologies
are commonly used what companies exist
out there who are the people working on
this stuff and so I think because of
that it's really important to be nimble
and make decisions that feel well
informed and are going to bring you to
where ever you want to go in your career
so let's get into what are some things
that I think about when making a career
decision and generally there's three
things for me the first thing and that
is kind of a prerequisite to all this
for me to consider any opportunity is
are my needs met this thing is
definitely balanced by the other two
points that I will get into but
basically it's just are my needs met am
I getting paid enough
do I have housing am I going to have
health care these are all really
important things for me in order for me
to do my best to work in a tech career
and tech careers are really demanding
and I need a lot of these things in
order to be myself and feel myself and
do good work and I know that I'm really
fortunate to be in this position and I'm
really privileged to be able to ask for
these things but it's given me a lot of
time to think about what I need in
life in order for me to live basically
and I think that I can the fact that I
can ask for these things means that I
should ask for them and I will ask for
them I mean ultimately it's also a lot
about like how much does the company
value me what are they willing to give
me in exchange for what work I do and
that has to be fair in some way and
whatever dollar value whatever else gets
put on it it has to feel mutual to me
because I want me to want them as much
as they want to need me and there has to
be some exchange of services and goods
there for it to work out so that's
number one just are my needs met like do
I have everything that I need in order
to do good work number two is related to
the hold or is in Jungle Jim analogy
which is what opportunities does this
open up for me and this requires a lot
of thinking on my part for what are some
of the opportunities that I need to gain
the skills that I want or experiences
that I want for me to get to my next
level and depending on where I am in my
career sometimes I don't know where like
the goal is per se I don't exactly know
what is the destination of where I want
to get to in my career but even if I
don't know that answer I know kind of
what are some of the skills that I want
to learn what are the incremental steps
that will help me at least uncover what
that goal is or get me to I don't know
be excited about my work or what are
some things that I'm just really curious
about learning or wanting to know or
build upon and just to spell out like
what I mean by opportunity it's things
like am I going to have the chance to
work on a project that'll help me learn
X Y & Z skill skills like technical
skills architectural skills speaking
skills communication skills
collaboration skills organization skills
like there's so many things there it's
also about the people who are there so
who are the people who are going to
teach me these skills who are people who
can mentor me and help me uncover what
my next goal in my career is going to be
what does their network look like who
can they introduce me to to do that if
they don't have those skills and these
are things that when I go to an
interview with a company I ask a lot of
questions about this
I try to meet as many people as possible
to get a sense of what are these
opportunities that exist here at this
company I also have conversations with
like my existing manager and existing
mentors to talk about hey I have these
things that I want to learn what are
some things that I could do to learn
these things
what are perspectives that I don't have
that you think would be helpful for me
to get to this next level so that's
number two what opportunities or doors
or next rungs of jungle tombs does this
opportunity reveal for me in the last
point which I personally think is the
most important thing for me when I'm
making a career decision is am I excited
about this I'm someone who really likes
trusting my gut I think I'm very honest
to myself when I do that and even though
it feels a logical your instinct is
developed by lots of little decisions
and experiences that you've had in the
past that maybe you can't tie them back
to you therefore it feels illogical but
I think it's an important thing to
really listen to yourself to say hey is
this something that just like genuinely
excites me is this something that gets
my heart rate up am I really excited to
like go after and do this thing does it
make me a little bit nervous because I'm
going out of my comfort zone but
ultimately is it going to be a good
thing for me these are really really
important questions that I ask myself
like I remember when I was applying to
patreon when I first saw the job posting
I remember just feeling this sense of
like I have to have this job because I
love this so much and I made my resume
and cover letter and day and I was just
like this is this is gonna happen just
go for it and those moments are really
special and I think it's a really cool
thing to experience and when you feel
that about an opportunity most of the
time it's going to be the right thing to
pursue so those are the three things
that I consider when making a career
decision in tech number one are my needs
met number two what opportunities is
this open up for me and number three am
i genuinely excited about this if you
have any other things that you consider
when you are making a career
decision then leave it in the comments
down below I think a lot of us consider
a lot of different things and depending
who you are you may weigh some things
heavier than the other and that's
totally normal we all have different
needs and different lives and different
priorities in life but those are the
ways that I find have been really
helpful for me in making my decisions
and I hope that they are helpful for you
too like I said be sure to check out the
podcast because we talked about
decisions literally decision making in
if/else so don't forget to check that
out in the description box down below
there really so special and well made
and I am so excited about this so I
really hope you enjoy them too if you'd
like to learn more about decisions so
that's it for today if you like this
video please give it a thumbs up and
don't forget to subscribe to my channel
and hit the notification bell I've got a
lot of videos coming out before the end
of the year so if you'd like to be
notified of them when they come out
please do that I would be so grateful to
know who is a part of this community and
that you like my stuff and that you want
to watch more of my videos alright well
that's it I hope you all have a great
day wherever you are bye
[Music]